right after Trump was arrested Trump got
directly into a vehicle and went
straight to the airport and flew back to
Florida
his attorneys held a sort of very
strange press conference right outside
the courthouse this is Joe takapina as
well as Trump's other lawyer whose Name
Escapes me at this exact moment in time
but we will find it it didn't go very
well it was just a complete and total
mess the only thing missing was holding
it at Four Seasons total landscaping or
whatever it was called Four Seasons
Landscaping but let's take a listen to a
little bit of this President not using
she requested that everybody involved
refrain from using language is
inappropriate and by the way that
includes that includes the witnesses the
witnesses for the people
um who are talking just as much includes
the former president swinging a baseball
bat at the head of the Manhattan D.A
well I don't know where you got that
because
swinging a baseball bat I mean if you
want to distort the facts go right ahead
I won't address that yes it is he wants
to swing a baseball bat at anyone's head
that was a picture of him showing off an
American-made bat he was talking about
how great American bats are yeah I mean
it's it's certainly a compilation
picture so takapina is right that the
picture was was isolated it was two
different pictures put together but
Trump did post it to truth Central and
we've got the picture up on the screen
it's a picture of Alvin Bragg side by
side with Trump holding a bat obviously
he wasn't actually holding a bat to
Alvin and Bragg's head but Trump did
post that to truth social
um let's look at another little bit of
that discussion
he requested that everybody involved
correct or trained from using languages
inappropriate and by the way that
includes that includes the witnesses the
witnesses for the people
um who are talking just includes the
former president swinging a baseball bat
at the head of the Manhattan D.A well I
don't know where you got that because
first of all first of all first of all
that picture was not even swinging a
baseball bat I mean if you wanted to
start the facts go right ahead I won't
address that yes it is he wasn't swing a
baseball bat at anyone's head that was a
picture of him showing off an
American-made bat but someone else put a
picture of the district attorney next to
him and in an article post that that's
not his own abundance program
using language that incites guys here's
what we're going to talk about today
here's what we're going to talk about
today we're going to talk about the
insufficiency of this case and I will
say this to you today's unsealing of
this indictment shows that the rule of
law died in this country because no
actually the indictment shows that no
one is above of the law and they keep
insisting that this means the rule of
the of law died no what we've learned is
not even a former president is above the
law and that's a great thing to learn
well everyone is not above the law no
one's below it either and if this man's
name was not Donald J Trump there is no
scenario we'd all be here today please
understand that based on these charges
all right so there's takapina and then
we have
um I guess one more clip here uh about
Trump's posts about the judge and the
judge's family messages
but as his attorneys have you told him
to stop posting this rhetoricity
literally we can't tell you what we've
discussed
the judge talking about the judge's wife
talking about the family I mean are you
I mean I don't think the judge was
concerned about it yeah but any other
defendant wouldn't you be like
going after the judge he is not going
after the judge he commented that he
thought that there were some issues that
may cause a conflict that's not going
after the judge he is not threatening
the judge he is not going after the
judge he has said that the deal you may
also notice that someone's holding the
leg of a mannequin over the head of
attorney Joe takapina during this entire
thing that's an important visual
component yeah he is angry because the
D.A has brought a case that is
unjustified and so I'm not going to
comment on it you may disagree with the
way he spoke about the process was he
fingerprinted was there a message
thank you for your attention all right
so then deciding that this was not going
particularly well for them and then
wrapping it up a wild day in lower
Manhattan let's take a very quick break
next we will talk about the event that
took place at Mar-A-Lago we're going to
hear from Lindsey Graham where there's
so much more Marjorie Taylor green was
run out of Manhattan trying to protest
it was one of the craziest day in
American politics in a long time we will
be back right after this and give you
the rest of the day's news